mukbang you can't just know about this
one it's been around for years why are
you making a video on this now to end
the year with a bang of course in case
for some reason you don't know what
mukbang is it's basically people shoving
food in their face for 30 to 40 minutes
it's like ASMR but in repulsive
apparently the trend of mukbang comes
from Korea that's right the Korean word
for exactly what it sounds like good
joke so this trend started in Korea
let's check out some Korean mukbang
I get it now that's super interesting
why is that man eating a her say
chocolate bar with chopsticks because
it's a mukbang of course I think the
reason why mukbangs are so popular is
because the thumbnail is just looking
Sain you just look at that nur and
you're like there's no way in hell
they're gonna actually eat that they're
just not happening and then you click
and watch it and you realize yeah no
they don't
apparently according to a mukbang
channel Korean Society has a tradition
of eating together but this culture is
now slowly dying away due to the
increase in one-person households now
people are starting to have the desire
to eat with someone and internet
broadcasters are solving this problem
Thank You internet broadcasters very
cool I can't really be too harsh it's
kind of similar to gameplay people
criticize that when that was new saying
why don't you just play the game
yourself huh why don't you just eat the
food yourself huh well it's fun to share
experience with others I do get that
combine that with the long videos and
really interesting thumbnails and bam
you got yourself a concept that's works
on YouTube good job everyone but there's
something about the content that I just
don't get it okay I feel old what can I
say I don't get it I don't get it at all
is it a kink thing
if someone just went out and said hey
you know what it's a king I bet all
right fine you know what you're weird
but whatever I'm sorry but watching this
guy eat a Hirsi chocolate with
chopsticks it's not doing it for me I'm
not getting those a.s.m.r tingles all
over I don't know if it's just me but I
can't stand personally I can't stand the
sound of slurping smacking or whatever
it is just eating on camera in general
is something that I try to avoid because
it's so goddamn disgusting I read
somewhere that it's a it's a genetic
thing I don't know if that's true or not
but you are more sensitive to hearing
those noises you don't want to hear them
I definitely had that gene okay I can't
stand it it's engrossed and apparently
they're aware of it if you don't like my
eating sound my smacking slurping simply
do not like me do yourself a favor and
don't watch I guess I guess they're used
to this criticism I am watching this
because we don't have food at home I
just I was just gonna ask like do people
not have food is that what the problem
is well I guess that's it then
okay problem so it's kind of like
watching a train wreck you know I don't
like it
but I'm still gonna watch it now
apparently in South Korea they the
government is cracking down on these
mukbang videos because of the obesity
increase over the past years apparently
obesity has increased from 2007 it was
31 percent to 34 point eight percent in
2016 in 1998 it was down at 26 percent
so now they're gonna develop guidelines
for these mukbang videos to crack down
on them whatever that means now I'm not
for government censoring or cracking
down on videos I think that's a bad move
in general and a lot of mukbang channels
are saying the same thing that this
really won't affect much and I probably
tend to agree with them but then again
you have mothers saying that their child
tried to stuff down as much
food a stomach bag streamer it was
watching you have this trend that's for
and it's a Korean thing but then the
Americans came and appropriated the
culture and oh boy it ain't pretty you
have something that it's already gross
in a different country it's not gonna
become less gross when Americans take
over it
now I don't know about you guys but I
like watching mukbang videos for their
insightful commentary
[Music]
okay all right remember when people said
that playing video games for a living it
requires no talent I remember and what
the hell is that okay so if I'm so grown
sacked by this if I'm so repulsed by
this concert why do I watch it why would
it make a video about it well I guess
you could say I'm fascinated
you have mukbang videos with the almost
18 million views it was also part of
YouTube rewind you may have seen it
[Music]
say I probably wouldn't have made a
video on this unless it wasn't rewind
but the final reason which we'll get
into later one of the biggest mukbang
channels is Mikado avocado I look
disgusting
I hate bead that I hate it
I've worked so hard at tried to lose
weight and look at me I don't know how
to get rid of this I have gained weight
and I don't even know why they work out
three times I eat plenty of fiber it's
like this happened overnight you know
everyone I think what I like most about
Nick nakata avocado is the fact that I
don't even have to watch his videos to
get a good laugh out of it and they
start these are all videos next to each
other I didn't really I didn't take any
of this out of context tragic news 5
packs black bean noodles why we broke up
hot Doritos cheesy pizza my deportation
pizza hot box what did I do to deserve
this delicious spicy seafood Korea Asian
McDonald's mukbang I had enough did you
some hotel room
eating bread disease this is the bit
they should have used for you to rewind
slightly edgy jokes now we can we can
have that sorry you're not in the rewind
promoting obesity to children let's make
a whole segment about that in YouTube
rewind that's a great idea
next up we have Veronica Wang and she's
the reason why this whole thing was even
brought to my attention because of my
sub reading one of the top voted oppose
this justice against Veronica now
apparently Veronica who's a mukbang
channel one of the biggest mukbang
channel she's been a naughty girl and
copy striking other people's content for
making fun of her so you have people
that smack on food and copy striking
people why why is that a common thing
now why is that a seventeen million
views everyone that's epic so apparently
she copies strike two two videos from
this channel called shook bang which
makes these you've probably seen these
type of videos they basically take their
their content and edit it to make it
look like something else for comedic
purposes hey Suge gang I got just got my
third copyright strike three strikes and
I'm out I guess this is a sign it wasn't
meant to be I just want to say it was
fun making y'all laugh here's a perfect
example of might say I know is PewDiePie
for two minutes straight it's taking the
out of context all the parts where my di
is ridiculing me as a joke wait don't
turn don't talk disgusting
just you're triggering me please this is
cringe camp you're making this now
apparently she had a problem with this
and coppy strike this channel and remove
those two videos and her response was
stuffy and I weren't like friends and
stuff or like I was being like super
evil and like was really greedy with the
food and stuff yeah that's the point of
these edits they're made for for fun and
people know it's not real to make it
seem like something is happening but
it's not really it's just a dumb edit I
bought a bunch of food I paid for all
the food I left all the food at
Stephanie's house like I was over 1 that
reminds Stephanie to like offer her
fiance food like no one cares Jesus
Christ so apparently she even uploaded
the same type of style video to her own
channel so it's kind of weird for her to
try and remove other ones but her
argument for this is that I'm
representing to my subscribers and I
want to show them that it's okay to
stand up for yourself so I made a video
of me making fun of myself literally a
video of me making fun of myself to show
people you know if anyone's gonna be
allowed to make fun of me it's gonna be
me so the only one that's allowed to
make fun of this person is herself and
no one else
great great message to show your fans
you know I'm okay with these type of
videos but I'm not okay with people
sending death threats and I'm not okay
with people can completely distorting my
character to make me seem like I'm this
horrible person this is not what these
videos are for and this is not what they
are sending other people to do this is
completely unrelated to these whole
events why am i focus on some stupid
mukbang drama I don't care but I think
it's important for the sake of YouTube
and how copyright is used yes if someone
used your video and added minimal edits
to it then yeah you could probably
copyright strike it because it's still
your video and YouTube doesn't really
interfere with that system they say well
if it's your video and you put a
copyright strike it we're just gonna
take it down unlike what Veronica said
which is completely wrong and it seems
like a common misconception for a lot of
people it's YouTube's responsibility to
see whether or not without the
responsibility
but the way that the copyrights work is
YouTube will take a look at it and see
whether or not they agree with the copy
yet that's not how it works they don't
mediate anything so it's very easy to
abuse copyright on YouTube and that's
why a lot of times I think it's
important for the community to step in
and say no that's the messed up you
shouldn't do that if for example this
sort of thing went to court and this
shook Bank video would some for some
reason decide you know what I didn't do
anything wrong here I'm gonna fight this
into court which is not gonna happen
obviously no no sensible person cares
about this that much but let's say it
did this parody channel would most
likely win because it's still fair use
they're adding their own edits to the
video they're adding their own text to
the video and it is transformative work
in that sense and what Veronica really
is doing is putting down videos that she
doesn't like which is a really bad
attitude in general to have we shouldn't
allow - for people to delete content
just because they don't like it but
since YouTube doesn't mediate these sort
of things and since this is literally
just going to be handled on YouTube she
can delete these videos and get these
channels that she doesn't like get
copyright strike now I don't think
Veronica is a terrible person I think
she just doesn't know how to handle
criticism and it's something that you
know a lot of new youtubers that aren't
used to criticism struggle with I
struggled with myself when I started
doing YouTube so I can't really fault
there too much but I do think genuinely
that she made a big mistake here and
that she should delete these strikes and
just apologize and move on it it's kind
of again the Streisand effect they we
see a lot on the internet and when
creators when different individuals try
and put remove something it just draws
more attention to it and even the
avocado guy he's clearly playing this
whole thing up for the sake of YouTube
it's not like he doesn't know what he's
doing it's not like he doesn't know why
he's gaining weight eating an unhealthy
amount you wouldn't eat that much in a
normal City mom no no no no right so why
are you doing it that amount of food
because it's a great excuse to get fat
so that's mukbang I guess I guess it's
the thing man it's been four years Felix
okay well I guess I'm a little late on
this one okay I guess there's a final
note that I wanted to shove in here
which is I stumble upon this well
sometimes I get so depressed
they'll be like at least a couple days
where I just stay in bed and I feel like
if I start looking at I was like
Veronica you know you've been depressed
for seven days six eight days nine days
ten days eleven days so I mean like oh
then the price for one week I've been
depressed for two weeks you know I
should think I should maybe start doing
huh because it's like the extent of it
when you look at it like three weeks Wow
I have no idea what she's trying to say
here but I think the point is a lot of
times when you're not happy you try and
fill that with something else whether
it's drugs or alcohol but I think a lot
of times what's overlooked is food I
think a lot of people you feel good by
eating you fill that void but I think
it's important to realize that's just a
craving that you have for the moment
that's just something that's gonna fill
your need for the moment but it's not
gonna leave you satisfied it's not gonna
make you happy in the end and I think
it's important to ask yourself why do
you have that craving why do you want to
eat so badly obviously eating this
copious amount of food isn't healthy
it's not a thing anyone should do but I
think that goes with anything am i
shoehorning too much a preachy message
in here absolutely hope you guys enjoyed
this vid here smash like subscribe and I
see you guys tomorrow
good bye show that you've done your part
by subscribing to PewDiePie but also buy
all the merch
wow that's epic I'll take 20 please you
can buy a poster a sticker alongside
hottest merch in the game thank you
[Music]